[Music]
hello welcome to JK news and I am rich
in earthshake news submitted by dialogic
I love that recent California
earthquakes have everyone concerned
about the next big one-oh know what's
gonna happen I love when it happens and
everyone just tweets earthquake just in
all caps
sweet yeah and everybody uploaded those
videos like of like their pools like
flooding like what yeah recent this
recent one me and Jill were watching TV
and I thought she was just shaking her
late really hard yeah they're all just
chillin I'm like - shake your [ __ ]
heart and I look at her legs and she
wasn't shaking and I look over to our
dog board we have a water dispenser
thing and then the water was just
slosher on it online
soju has wrestled function though I
really don't I'm about to do I'm riddled
with it yeah me too I thought she was
shaking her really don't like to make
fun of me and they they say they can
make fun of my disease but I think it's
[ __ ] up it is [ __ ] up you can't do
anything about it no how do people make
fun of you well my wife who likes is
like stop doing that and I'm like it's a
[ __ ] disease yeah yes there were two
earthquakes recently there was a 6.4 in
a 7 point 1 and the 6.4 magnitude one
was on 4th of July and it happened in
the epicenter was near Ridgecrest yeah
on the way to Vegas and then so they're
saying that there were like over a
hundred more a little aftershock sighs
oh my lord
yeah it is a gross weight do you have
that thing where you can't look at dots
yeah damn it seeds looks like little
ants Davis isn't it just like freaks out
it's a disease the July 4th one they're
calling that a foreshock yeah it's i've
never heard that
but it is more shock for the 7.1 you
know there's aftershock this Oh like
foreplay foreplay shop with the 7.1 is a
foreshock room that's what scares me
trap some people were saying yeah so
they're saying like recent like now we
really have to do but they've been
saying this for a year but we've never
felt shipped before yeah we have yeah we
have the 94th quickened Bert 94 to do
you can say that it was the most recent
craziest one in my last 20 years
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying but one
in a minute in most of the ridge rich
crest though Wow because the Northridge
was like a 6.5 or something or whatever
sixth elements like without this
devastating because it was in the LA
County so there was like bridges and it
like slate and move we were living in
like like Northridge ish more you guys
were the ballet and we're in the valley
and hit us like really hard to do
chimney follow I was too so do you
remember anything I just remember this
that's all so I slept through it
oh wow I was an elementary school how
were you living on I was in Gardena
so that's South Bay so by then yeah it
probably didn't I was sleepy at home I
was sleeping my mom woke me up to feel
it wake up hell you should look kid like
what this is what earth quake is like
she should have just went to sleep it my
dad's an insurance agent so like I think
because he does he deals like car like
earthquake all that stuff this is a
dream come true like well he's like he's
like [ __ ] I have to like pick up calls
now so it's like so he has to work yes
your dad doesn't want to do all his
business
you know they're not doing well can I
get the pee oh yeah they don't want yes
for you through you for your dad is
theirs quick insurance worth it because
I don't know if I should get it yeah
Walter in California yeah okay it
doesn't matter it depends on what they
insured by the way yeah because because
I own the inside of my apartment or some
[ __ ] but I don't own the building so I'm
responsible for the inside of my
apartment so earthquake insurance is
stupid because my building covers that I
wouldn't even know what to do like so
I felt the seven point when I was the
tiger I don't know where you were and
then like you know that was maybe that
you know that's the one that felt like
it took forever and I was like okay cool
it's shaking and then I'm like alright
it's gonna stop and the nothing and take
a seat next to me I'm like okay is this
the point where I'm supposed to run
outside now cuz it's not stopping and
then I'm like [ __ ] what do I do am I
supposed to run outside don't ever run
outside know what to do but you grew up
here I did but I only knew it in
elementary school under the desk and
where's my [ __ ] desk at home I will
tell you well stamen go away that no
well the most recent one that I read the
most recent one that I read is that they
do want you to go outside if there's
nothing see there's nothing that could
fall on you that's a baby oh yeah if
you're in the desert now we're in the
desert
no but you live next to teléfono that's
right your new area is pretty super
pretty you're not you don't to be near
trees or power lines or any of it
exactly it's something for you
personally I just go in your backyard
it's perfect saying that if you're
inside and like you and outsides more
dangerous you have to go under a sturdy
table but if you don't exactly you're
supposed to always like duck and cover
your neck yeah what about babies oh what
am I supposed to cover doorways are the
are one of the most safest places
because of its by the frames and then
it's it's it's you yours protected by
the houses like what do you call it the
structure so always though they didn't
mention the doorway thing but I do
remember hearing that so yeah and then
but they also mention like if you're in
a like an open space room that you don't
have anything to go under then you just
have to duck and cover your vital organs
in your neck thing to do yeah you're I'm
not gonna look like an idiot during an
earthquake okay I remember an elementary
schooler with duck under the table and
cover our head and neck that's important
and then we would also hold on to the
leg of the table so that table doesn't
have that's life isn't slide tomorrow
some of this [ __ ] it's like in the 60s
when they did like the the nuclear bomb
drill and as I get under your desk and
cover your head like blowing smoke in
your face
yeah [ __ ] exactly they had an
earthquake drill like every single
semester yeah yeah and they would walk
us outside other classes too like you're
like standing in line in the video that
you're like I'm nice and presents like a
breath of fresh air are you going to the
kated kid you go under the table and
it's like flip your friends off shoo
turtles were not fun oh yeah those are
new well no but what I did those was
yeah same here
sure this is number 11th they were like
like making sure a lot of things so what
was sick about the earthquake drills is
that I didn't know anyone who died in
the earthquake or like I never heard of
that [ __ ] you know I mean we you know
what's crazy and this one there's most
recent one there saying that there might
be a like the first death oh wait wait
how so they were saying that this guy he
was in Nevada he was working on on his
car it's like oh my god like he did with
the jacket yeah thank you he did jack it
up like properly yeah um and but his
death wasn't reported until four days
later when people were like we worries
it's four days yeah so the car smashed
them yeah it moves like
they're trying they're determining
whether or not that was caused by the
earthquake but I think it was yeah based
on the timeline
oh good shake artist [ __ ] I don't like
it it moved in like a crush oh god I
hope he died fast I know he probably
didn't I was with Nicky it's like the
earth is still shaking like that I was
with I was with Nicky and we were in
Santa Barbara so I fourth I think right
that was when the seven-point whatever
yeah and we're all doing July 5th
we're all drinking outside we're having
a barbecue and I remember being like
wait am I like getting really [ __ ] up
I thought it was really drunk so I
didn't want to see me we're at the right
right we were yeah we were we were by
the by the beach yeah it was pretty much
hate aftermath of an earthquake I loved
I mean it sounds weird but I do love the
actual earthquake because it's like Oh
an adrenaline cuz I've never been
seriously I know I prefaced it when I
know it sounds weird but it's not really
weird
well these earthquakes were nice exactly
like nothing was ever it was just like
your house is surfing a little bit yeah
talk to the guy under the car man yeah
aftermath of it I get vertigo though cuz
I'm like I'm still [ __ ] dizzy cuz I'm
like is it still shaking like stuff yeah
I went for a while oh [ __ ] what's
shaking flight 48 was we didn't feel
like though cuz we were in Aruba oh we
missed the earth I like that bloke I
heard about it through Twitter no I was
like damn it I missed an earthquake yeah
I didn't I wasn't part of the earthquake
cuz I was in England dining with the
Queen where you guys are like all at
like like probably like five stories and
under when it happened yeah it says I
was in Japan for like for one of our
tours and then I think we were like on
like 20-something youth floor and I
literally like any earth little baby
earthquakes happen really frequently
there but I was sleeping and then
suddenly I wake up and it goes oh no and
I was like freaking the [ __ ] out because
we're on like 20 thump was probably
amplifier yeah it was like that I felt
everything shake and it was just
terrifying so I don't like luckily you
know Callie's
Louie show you has that nice drill to do
we got a different cartwheel and they
try to I don't give a [ __ ] like I
experienced close to six points
something when we were out there yeah
and that was we were closer to the
epicenter yeah and I was in a museum
with Jess and this museum it wasn't like
one structure it looks like a boat on
stilts yeah so it will that's what the
structure looks like it's kind of like a
architectural cool art artistic design
or it looks like it's just on like four
legs yeah and then but my mom was saying
like all these buildings that are like
super modern and all that they're like
the safest ones too made for huh but it
was hella scary though cuz it was like
earthquake not the wavy one that's
always been wavy for me yeah 8:21 here
on the air works very very strong you're
very professional for like constantly
going
the basic thing to feel yeah hi
like video people hang around you reach
the Las Vegas should be added of montage
we've got dead weight pool and [ __ ]
according to that there's this new crack
yeah and now it's being a actual tourist
attraction people are going there and
taking photos why are why are you going
towards the D why do people go to the
biggest the world's biggest yarn ball
okay so where is it I want to go so that
form during the whole earthquake yeah
this is a brand new imagine just being
there and seeing that open imagine
you're standing each leg you're like
doing a split I was coming to earth I
think we can all rest assured that
Bart's mom would wait make sure he's
awake to see
[Music]